li à 110 d'arcachon n'existait pas il y
à 30 ans à peine on allait au canon à
eau à l'herbe en charrette alors sont
arrivés les estivants dans les années 60
les touristes découvrent le cap ferret
cette presqu'île sauvage à 50 km de
bordeaux n'était alors qu'un village de
pêcheurs
très rapidement le paysage va changer
car les touristes sont séduits et
s'installe enfin construisent ici au cap
ferret ce merveilleux endroit de
vacances ou une villa neuve est terminée
tous les trois jours et où la population
passe l'été de 2000 à 40 milles à mes
débuts des années 70 un projet va
diviser habitants commerçants et
touristes la construction d'un port de
plaisance au mimbeau cette flèche
sableuses du cab
face à la mobilisation des opposants un
référendum est organisé
je demande à tous les enfants les jeunes
les usagers les plaisanciers de venir
dire ce qu'il désire est ce qu'il ne
désire pas contre certains votes
bétonnage quand une appropriation du
domaine public
c'est avec ce combat que les habitants
du cap ferret ont commencé à se
mobiliser pour préserver leur bout de
paradis
je veux tu as peur ça leur est une ville
au cap ferret je veux que ça ne vient
que ça reste comme ça
le projet du port de plaisance sera
abandonné mais malgré ça les touristes
ne cessent d'envahir les lieux exemple
en 1989 au cap ferret 6000 habitants
l'hiver 120000 l'été 20 fois plus un
tourisme important qui aiguise l'appétit
des promoteurs immobiliers en 2000 le
maire disait résister à cette pression
immobilière
et pour cause la pointe du lège cap
ferret est une zone fragile menacée par
l'érosion partout il ya un périmètre de
risque aucune construction n'est
possible l'adaptation de l'habitat est
possible adaptation ça veut dire la
construction d'une véranda transforme un
barrage en garage en chambre etc
mais des nouvelles constructions ça
n'est plus possible ces noms de façon
très claire
plus aucune nouvelle construction
possible ce qui entraîne une pression
immobilière impressionnante jusqu'à dix
neuf mille euros le mètre carré
c'en est trop pour les pêcheurs qui ne
peuvent même plus acheter de cabanes
leur outil de travail
prisé par les
suivant les jeunes aujourd'hui mais
s'ils peuvent pas faire le métier
ils vont quitter la presqu'île il y aura
plus ce qui a fait ce qu'elle était à
savoir la pêche l'ostréiculture
c'est pourtant les fondamentaux c'est ça
qui a créé là les villages d'ailleurs en
toute chose faut le rappeler 1870 les
villages chez les pêcheurs les
ostréiculteurs
c'est pas les avocats c'est pas les
notaires le lège cap ferret quand 8000
habitants à l'année pour sept mille
résidences secondaires mais la
presqu'île est en danger l'océan
grignote cette langue de sable déjà la
plage de la pointe est interdite au
public
[Musique]